[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous Gabriel Gontier
on commence avec des problème de
transport dans le sud des ivelines oui
Mathilde et la colère gronde du côté des
usagers des transports en commun dans le
sud du département la raison Mathilde
depuis le 1er janvier la gestion du
trafic des Transports a changé de main
c'est maintenant l'entreprise Transdev
sudivelin qui gère le secteur problème
cette dernière fait face à une pénurie
de conducteurs pour assurer le service
et notamment dans le secteur de la
Vallée de Chevreuse conséquence certains
élèves n'ont pas de bus pour aller à
l'école une situation jugée
incompréhensible par les maires de la
Vallée de Chevreuse ils ont saisi
île-de-fance mobinité et sa présidente
Valérie pécrè selon les élus la
situation n'évoluera pas à court terme
un mot de football à présent Gabriel le
parisain-germain pourrait construire un
stade dans les Yvelines oui tout à fait
si le club cl de la capitale ne parvient
pas à racheter le Parc des Princes il
pourrait décider de construire un
nouveau stade pour cela il y a quatre
options qui sont envisagé dont une à
Montini le Bretonneux alors le PSG
serait intéressé par un terrain basé
près du Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en yeline un site
accessible avec le rerc et qui séduit
les dirigeants parisiens grâce à sa
proximité avec le nouveau Training
Center de poissie le maire de la commune
Laurent Merker ne ferme pas la porte à
ce pro et on reste à Montini le
Bretonneau Gabriel où ce soir auront
lieu les assises de l'éducation oui ça
se passe à partir de
19h45 dans la salle Jacques brê la
commune organise ses assises de
l'éducation objectif Imagineer la
construction de l'école primaire de
demain avec la participation des parents
des agents périscolaires et l'éducation
nationale ce projet doit être
opérationnel pour la rentrée 2025 on
écoute l'adjoint au maire Yannick LEDOR
Montini comme l'ensemble des villes de
l'agglomération est issue de la ville
nouvelle nous avons connu une très forte
et un très fort développement
démographique lors des années 90 et
aujourd'hui on a un tassement de cette
évolution démographique avec évidemment
un impacte sur nos écoles inimontaines
que ce soit pour les enfants de maternel
ou les enfants de l'élémentaire et
l'idée c'est bah d'anticiper sur les
évolutions à venir et euh de programmer
la nouvelle école que nous voulons à
Montini pour les années à venir pour
suivre cette soirée rendez-vous sur le
compte Youtube de la commune à partir de
19h45 et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 new